welcome
thanks for joining us today we're going
to be talking about analyzing
distributed traces to find performance
bottlenecks in your system
i'm brian zimmerman product manager with
google cloud
and i'm francis i work on distributed
tracing at shopify
and i'm also a maintainer of open
telemetry ruby
in order to speak about performance
troubleshooting first let's talk about
performance problems
these are problems with the latency or
compute utilization of your services
and these are things that will impact
your users experience of your product
and your bottom line these are often
difficult because there is no clear
error or event that has caused the issue
instead they may be an optimization that
has existed in your system for a while
or there could be a problem that is
creeped up or is otherwise buried
performance problems in large
distributed systems can be surprising
and causality is often missing or buried
in other telemetry signals
a couple of real examples we found with
distributed tracing at shopify
an rpc was executed twice
unintentionally due to a quirk in the
network architecture
and a value in memcache that grew in
size without anyone noticing
and then suddenly became popular during
a flash sale exhausting network link
capacity
both of these jumped out really quickly
from trace data
today we're going to be highlighting a
couple key tools
from the cloud observability toolset
first is cloudtrace
this is a distributed tracing tool that
is particularly useful for latency
scenarios
but it's also useful in any scenario
where a downstream service
is affecting upstream behavior then
there's cloud profiler
this is a continuous profiling
application that helps you find exactly
what part of your code is responsible
for an issue
these exist as part of a larger tool set
this tool set is based off the same
planet scale platform that powers
google's internal observability
so you know it's been battle tested in
addition it comes with zero day
configuration
out of the box for key google services
so for those who aren't familiar let's
talk about what distributed tracing is
here's an example application
architecture your users may communicate
with the front end through load
balancers
that will communicate and turn to
multiple backends including databases
today your application is more likely to
look like this
many small micro services working
together for a common goal
this is a great application architecture
but becomes very difficult to
troubleshoot
distributed tracing allows you to
understand exactly how the request has
moved through this environment
which definitely simplifies
troubleshooting scenarios
at shopify we're often known for our
devotion to our core monolith
in reality though there's an
increasingly large set of services
orbiting that monolith and performance
is impacted by all services involved in
processing a request
including third-party services
distributed tracing provides visibility
into the performance of these
increasingly deep distributed systems
that is almost impossible to achieve any
other way
next let's review continuous profiling
continuous profiling helps specifically
with what happens
in a particular service the intent is to
identify the method or section of code
that is contributing to the issue or the
source of the optimization
cloud profiler takes profiles of your
application at every function call
in a sampled way this means it's
perfectly safe to run in production
these profiles are laid out on a flame
graph where it's visually
extremely easy to understand how these
functions play together
and where the cause of an issue is
when we talk to customers the
troubleshooting process
typically follows these steps you start
with
an issue and refine that issue as much
as possible using the metrics you have
then you try to identify the service
that's responsible
this is particularly important for
distributed systems
further refining to the method or part
of your code where the issue exists
is extremely important for efficient
troubleshooting
and then finally looking at deep
information such as logs and debugging
tools
help you come up with a viable
hypothesis for what might be causing the
issue
this is of course required before any
resolution can be attempted
which needs to be pushed and confirmed
using the same metrics that
identified the problem for you in
practice we can treat traces
as contextualized logs typically trace
instrumentation initially focuses on the
edges in a service graph
where communication happens between
services performance problems show up as
large spans with large gaps between
child spans
where we don't know what's going on so
the hypothesis part of our process
involves incrementally filling in those
empty spaces by adding instrumentation
to our code
until we gain some insight into what is
different about this path
now let's see this in action using
google cloud's observability suite of
products
we're going to show you a series of
demos on our demo application
online boutique we'll take you from
problem
to service to method to hypothesis
starting with identifying and refining
the problem
we're going to show how to use cloud
monitoring to find and refine the
problem you're attempting to investigate
as you can see here we already have an
incident related to latency
you can see from looking at the policy
details that we've actually defined this
alert
to be 99th percentile latency sustained
for one minute
this kind of alert configuration ensures
that only real problems
generate alerts and wake up our on-call
tech
to understand the problem further we're
going to open up one of our
pre-configured dashboards in this case
the performance dashboard
we can see a definite spike in latency
in our server latency heat map this can
be shown both from the aggregate
percentile lines
as well the distribution itself let's
drill into the inflection point
at this point we definitely understand
what to investigate
which is grpc server latency
next we're going to use distributed
tracing to understand the source of that
latency spike
with the problem well understood it's
time to identify the service
where the issue most likely exists
to investigate the cause of this latency
we're going to use a new feature called
example traces
this allows us to overlay sampled traces
onto the latency heat map from within
the monitoring dashboard
here we can drill into the specific
requests
that generated those metric data points
of interest
in this instance it's quite obvious to
see that most of the time is spent
during the get product operation
we can check other requests to see if
it's a similar pattern
and indeed it is
to validate our hypothesis let's check
some 50th percentile traces
from before the spike
to investigate this further we're going
to open cloudtrace
here we can further dig into the traces
that exemplify this problem
this allows us to filter for additional
details including label values
and see the trend over time as you can
see
the visual representation of your entire
request that trace provides
allows you to easily see where the
problem is in this case as mentioned
earlier
it seems to be in the product catalog
service get product operation which is
done repeatedly
and has been taking a much longer time
than looking at traces from before the
spike
kellyanna is going to show you how you
can use google cloud profiler
to identify where in the code this issue
or
optimization can be found now we will
use
google cloud profiler to investigate
which functions in your service code
could be slowing it down
the default view of profiler shows you a
flame graph
representation of your service profile
in this flame graph we can get a
purchase view of various
is spending most of its time here we
have selected
the product catalog service and we are
specifically looking
at the cpu time for the service
just by looking at the flame graph we
can understand that most of the time is
spent
in this stack which is the grpc
receiver for this service walking down
the stack
we can see that pass catalog is pending
is where you are spending most of your
time opening the top functions
table and sorting by the total time
we can confirm that
68 of the total time is spent in parse
catalog
walking down the stack some more we can
see
that this time is spent in actually a
json and marshalling function
so this should be the first focus of our
optimization efforts
to form a viable hypothesis we're going
to use
logging and debugging tools included
with google cloud observability suite of
products
we're going to jump to the related logs
for this particular trace
in the previous demo we found that the
cause of the problem was most likely
within the product catalog
service to dig into this further
we're going to filter to that particular
kubernetes resource pod
this can be done easily at the click of
a button and
immediately via the histogram it's
obvious that something has changed
around the time of this issue
let's jump to the start of this problem
to see what's happening
similar to what we saw within profiler
this service
is successfully parsing the product
catalog very very often and repeatedly
certainly more than it was previous to
the issue starting
this confirms our hypothesis that the
problem is related
to parsing of the product catalog to
further dig into this we can inspect the
messages from our logs
correlate that with the behavior of our
code via debugger
and our ide
cloud debugger allows you to inspect
what's happening within your running
application
by injecting snapshots or log points
whenever you like in your code we'll
show this in action
by going to our currency service
and let's take a snapshot at line 155.
what we can see here on the right hand
side is instantly
we're able to see details of the local
variables at the time the snapshot was
taken
now what if you only want to take that
snapshot in certain
circumstances maybe i'm chasing an issue
with only a certain
region or a certain user well you can
add conditions
these are written in the language of the
code that you're debugging or
expressions
which will print certain aspects of your
application
as you write them now maybe i don't want
a snapshot that occurs once but i want
to in a recurring basis take a log point
well you can do that you can inject log
points that will be run every time the
code is hit not just once
and again these can be written with any
condition written in the language of the
code you're debugging
and with any message the editor allows
you to do this easily
you can write whatever log point you
want as long as it will not affect
the running byte code and it meets
certain memory or cpu
footprint requirements
these features allow you to understand
what's happening within your actual
production application
this can be a game changer when it comes
to understanding
and debugging issues that only happen on
production
it also makes it much easier for
operators sres or developers
to troubleshoot issues without having to
wait for long deployment cycles
the demos you've just seen gives you a
highly guided experience to troubleshoot
performance problems
using google cloud's observability suite
of products
but sometimes the answer is not that
simple there isn't a single request
or even a set of logs that shows you
exactly where the problem is
this is where understanding the system
and its requests in aggregate is
extremely important
in order to help with this we've
recently released
a feature where traces can be exported
to bigquery
any label that you send into your span
data gets written as unique columns
which makes searching even easier
this allows you to use the power of
bigquery to perform custom analysis
and also allows you to retain data for
much longer than the included 30 days
now i'm going to hand things over to
francis who's going to explain how this
kind of aggregate analysis is done at
shopify
at shopify we use bigquery for aggregate
choice analysis
i'm going to briefly demonstrate how we
do that
firstly though why do we need aggregate
analysis the typical approach to trace
analysis is to search for interesting
traces perhaps by service and time frame
and either incrementally refine our
search until we have a smallish set of
traces
to look at or hope that the thousand or
so traces returned are representative of
what we're looking for and start
clicking randomly
by viewing a few random traces we're
hoping that anything interesting we find
is representative of a larger set of
traces
using a tool like bigquery however we
can analyze all the traces in a set and
allow it to surface interesting
information
we still often want to look at complete
traces to provide more context
but we'll have confidence that the
traces we look at will be truly
representative
if we want to use bigquery for trace
analysis we have to get the trace data
into it somehow
there's a couple of ways you can do this
for example at shopify
we have a slightly complex ingestion
pipeline using the open telemetry
collector pops up gcs
and batch upload to bigquery google
cloud trace provides a simpler option
with trace exports
the schema that cloudtrace uses for
trace data in bigquery is determined by
the trace v2
api definition of span so it stores one
span per row with nested records for
span attributes
shopify schema is similar but based on
the open telemetry protocol definition
of span instead
if we're performing in depth analysis of
something relatively constrained
our first step is always to extract the
data we're interested in into its own
table
this can drastically reduce query costs
leverage the query cache and generally
increase responsiveness in this example
we're going to analyze synthetic load
generated against the test shot
almost all of the units of work
performed by our core monolith whether
requests or background jobs are scoped
to a single shot
so we always tag request in job spans
with the target shop id
we know the time interval for the load
test and the id of the test shot
our table is partitioned by start time
so we specify that as our first filter
we're doing a bunch of analysis it has
no obvious partitioning or clustering
characteristics so we don't bother
specifying clustering or partitioning
for our destination table
we use the subquery to identify trace
ids that meet our requirements and then
copy
all the spans from those traces to the
new table
here we've extracted about 8 gigabytes
and 13.5 million spans from a 22
terabyte partition
this significantly reduces the working
set for analysis
let's start our analysis with some basic
queries to figure out the services
involved in red metrics
it doesn't get much simpler than this
this gives us a list of the services
involved
red metrics are a little more
complicated let's focus on one service
the storefront rendering we'll count
requests per minute
filtering to the service and looking
only at service bands
the key pieces here are truncating the
start time then grouping and ordering by
the truncated start time
we can see around 45000 rpm over the
first half of the test
followed by a dip and then an increase
to around 175
000 rpm in the second half i should note
here that we're down sampling traces in
the collectors
so we saw a significant multiple of this
request rate but this serves to show the
general shape of the load
note that we can trivially adjust this
query to return a per second request
rate
the bigquery console is great for trying
out queries but once we start building
queries like this
we want to easily visualize the results
there are many tools that integrate with
bigquery including google sheets and
data studio
at shopify we use mode analytics for
data analysis
in mode we build our sql queries
separately and then we can access the
data sets by name in a notebook
plotting our query results is pretty
trivial here are the plots from our
earlier queries
and from a similar query for request
rate to our core monolith
to calculate duration as a distribution
we bucketize by a minute and compute
each percentile over each minute
we represent duration in microseconds so
here i'm converting to milliseconds
and here's what that looks like as a
plot before we drill in further
one more high level perspective we might
like is the relationship between the
services involved
and the relative volume of traffic this
is variously called a service graph
or service map here's what that looks
like in this example
the key pieces we need to know are the
source destination and request count for
each edge in the graph
the query required for this is a little
more complicated
but there's really two things going on
here the first part of this query
considers requests that are represented
by a single span
these are typically database or cache
queries where we only have the
instrumentation on the client side
the other set of requests we're
interested in have two sides
so we grab the set of time spans with
the tracing span ids and the set of
server stands with the tracing parents
fan ids
and then join them on the trace id where
the parent span
id of the server is the client span id
grouping gives us the request count
along each edge
so let's go deeper and break down
request counts and durations by
component
for request count we query the rails
controller attribute as well
and group by both start time and the
controller in some cases the attribute
is missing so we replace it with unknown
plotting this gives us a request rate
for the different controllers
breaking down the duration by controller
is slightly more gnarly
i built this query in the bigquery
console by trial and error and a data
analyst somewhere is probably having a
fit watching me try to play one on tv
regardless our sub query extracts the
start time controller and duration from
the relevant stands
and then we compute the p95 partition by
the start time and controller
the result is a little obscure by an
outlier controller which looks like the
not found controller
we could ignore this controller in the
sql query but it's easier to do it here
with pandas
this produces a much clearer breakdown
drill downs are also relatively easy
with padders
here we've drilled down into the
collections controller we can then
easily contrast the duration for this
controller
with the request rate for the controller
from our earlier query
now we might want to ask where we're
spending time in aggregate in request to
this controller
let's start by querying all the
operations performed during those
requests
we have 26 operations which is quite
manageable
we have the expected redis and mysql
queries and template parsing and
rendering
computing the workload contribution of
each operation is as simple as summing
the duration and grouping by the
spamming
ordering by the cumulative duration
allows us to quickly identify the heavy
hitters
the top two aren't interesting but the
rest are leaf spans and we can clearly
see my sql dominates followed by redis
we can further summarize my database
type to see the cumulative my sequel and
radius times
in this service we also tag spans with
the time spent in garbage collection
which we can then extract and summarize
we're interested to know whether gc
dominates any of the expensive
operations
in fact it doesn't it accounts for less
than one percent of time spent in my sql
spans
and a little over four percent of
overall request time
alternatively we can look at the
contribution of different sql queries
in this service we tag my sql query
spans with a digest of the query
template
which makes it easy for us to aggregate
spans and then we can search for
examples and find the actual queries in
another tag
here we see one query clearly dominates
finally in the same way we did with
controllers
we can analyze request rate and duration
by arbitrary tags
this is a request count by the zone
and this is a p95 duration by zone we
can see some small differences but
nothing especially exciting
if we instead look at cash hit versus
missed performance we can see a more
distinct difference
and we can see that our cash hit rate is
reasonable
at over 96 i hope that's given you a
taste of some of the types of analyses
that you can perform over trace data
using bigquery the key elements are
getting trace data
into bigquery which you can accomplish
with cloud trace export
then extracting interesting traces to a
separate table
typically based on a time window this
helps to control query costs
and greatly increases responsiveness and
finally
it's extremely helpful to have a tool to
view the query results
at shopify we use mode analytics but
there are many other tools that
integrate with bigquery
thank you francis and thank you all for
joining
please feel free to reach out for
follow-up and as always
visit us at cloud.google.com